we're talking about vaccine distribution
even a winter snowstorm
in seattle could not stop a 90 year old
from getting her coveted shot
fran goldman there she is she walked six
miles guys
through nearly a foot of snow to make
sure she got vaccinated it took her
weeks to book the appointment and she
did not want to miss it driving was of
course out of the question so she
layered up and braved the snow on foot
she said the medical staff was shocked
that she made the hike
they said you've got to sit down and
wait for 15 minutes and i said i'll be
delighted to sit down for 15 minutes
i've been walking here
goldman said she wanted to get the shot
so she could hold her new great
grandchild his name is silas
she also has a new hip and she said she
wanted to put it to good use she's 90.
folks she's 90. i got a new hip vlad i
want to use it i love what her daughter
ruth said your daughter ruth said her
mom
she's someone who looks for solutions
not a problem you know she also
somebody gave her a ride back please no
she walked back
back yeah she looked like that looked
like an easy walk whoa no there was a
trail it was a trail that she followed
in other people's footsteps
um what's interesting she talked about
getting the polio vaccine
back in the 1950s and she contrasted
that with the distribution of that
vaccine
and how everybody believed in the
science everybody got the vaccine that
needed it
to the period i don't think i could walk
six miles and then six months
in the snow i don't need a new hit
myself i think that's a great ad for hit
replacement don't be scared it works
that's right it really does